вибір че кодекс прийняті верховною радою
україни по стрибні! обзивався на і
красивий європейських практиках треба серед
польші франції інших європейських країв
дуже читку я прив'язка депутата дороги
ну і е партійно конкуренція це ще б пак
можна було продавати за списком не лише
лояльних до партійних бонз
річки ясна курі стоїте популярністю піт
ринку з самих вибірки і добре сьогодні
ось вся система стояти за грізну я
майже на волосся то ще а по стрибні
парламент візьму відкрито не наш
політична команда забув і все для
того був вимкни ти можна весь нитку по
вибірці сіті гречка і всі ті лікарі сеті
кульок і спаду ринків називалися
процесу вибір сил купу на волосся то
рахунок ключовику руб тіні your мовою він і
засмічення jeunesse найбільш на виборах з
мажоритарних округах запали допомагають
гречка та лікарі та владне зелений річки
прийшов нагадати брехні до влади вбити
про я хочу на волосся цієї вибір team зага
ліску роцит та парламент до 300 депутатів
і проводять і вибори вимкнено за
партійним спискам і чим і чому сьогодні
рейтинг слух народу летіти в тартар і
двір кратні мого життя дружині сьогодні
Петро їм коті та партії це відривається ще
на по суті плитку за вибіркою
рахунок того ванну і тисячі to take 2 на
вали як єдність і владно вже нема
їжджу дно голосування річці база б
скачується не слуги народу тисну
але їм аімн з 226 голосі всі закони
особливий вал бійське kurupt тіні кадрові
про значення бюджет не приймає за
допомогою з їх групи або гірчичних
мажоритарних до віра та за можуть не через
розкалів ж рублях за я ви просто шукаю
знову повернутися вдома жир янтарна
системи типу porsche і так само
розплата за зими групам ми затягнемо
підвалу совувати подруга такі
політичні хабар шепси групи і дали
чув ліся в банковій орбіті і до
допомагала і голосова тягнув на вимагав
розпускати парламент
3 такої ампулі тисяч на проспект та loose
жити і так звання за мої будні і
Деверо депутати не мати деяких партія
хоче зал і хитайся вирішувала my і ніби у
доступному парламенті та 4 самі слухай і
зелений а за астані xiv вибірник
компанії ківі бійся в Україні за чисел
уряд заїнського показав ще на
виборах них теж відчуваючи адмінресурс petcube
але особливим адмінресурсу за ленський сам
просив я таким біп агітатором цей слух
народу так було на франків чиніди ви
бували просто тобі час мови іра скла
так було на черкащині так було petcube
по суті на добре ще не так просто
набирає іншого кандидата про значило на
державну по саду для того, щоб хлопець
з слуга народу і владно встю практику
адмінресурсу та гречки слуги хоче і
просто потикатися на всій території
україни якщо думали чим доступне
парламенті на роки на тисячу монади 6
у завалюй який фракції мед винний
хочеш атакувати таких ресурсних як він
називають депутатів ми буде їх пізно
ходіть по закріплю його ти через округи
та й патча то таким чином фальсифікатор
ж на старті вибори та й ми гру маски
організації та в самі українці я думаю
ріка товариш навпроти його треба міг
повернути і диктатуру і від ультразвуку та